Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
OK.
Let's go back to the phones at six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty, starting
with our caller from the two zero two area
code who's calling today from two zero to.
Hi, can you hear me?
Yes, who's this?
Hi, David.
My name is owner and I'm calling from the
D.C. area.
Long time listener for some color.
Love him and thanks.
I'm wondering if you have any advice for race.
But my focus the next few months leading up
to the election, I have some friends who say
they won't vote, provided for various reasons
because they're unsatisfied with the fact
that he is not adopting enough or adopt smart
adopting enough progressive policies that
his platform.
Others say because of the allegations against
him, they feel they can't vote for him.
Hold on.
Which I don't care what at what allegations.
Sorry, Tara Revalidation.
Oh, you have friends who are saying now and
in September that they can't vote for Biden
because of the terror allegations.
Yes.
Wow.
And so I for obvious reasons, I don't want
to have to.
Debate up with them.
But so many if I should even try and talk
to them or if I should.
Because I am getting involved with organizing
programs in other states right off swing states
like Pennsylvania and Michigan.
So should I just put my energy there?
Well, I was going to say allow these friends
of yours that they don't want to vote for
Biden because of terror.
Reid's allegations.
What where are they voting?
So, like I said, I'm in the D.C. area.
Mostly there, so I do have some friends from
college.
I went to college in a swing state.
And so, listen, we've got we've got weeks
left until this election.
I would not waste any time arguing with people
who are voting in Washington, D.C.
Number one, Washington, D.C. is going to go
overwhelmingly to Joe Biden.
It's an exercise in futility and frustration.
So right off the bat, save yourself the time.
Chop that completely out of out of what you're
working on now.
Virginia is interesting.
I think that there may be maybe there's an
opportunity to get involved in Virginia.
But the truth is that right now with phone
banking, you can decide to help in any state
you want to help.
And if you want to, if you look at the Georgia
numbers and you say, wow, Georgia's closer
than it normally is, I'm going to help phone
bank in Georgia to get out the vote because
it will force Trump to have to spend resources
there.
Maybe you do that.
Maybe you say, well, Wisconsin is a likely
state to be the difference maker electorally.
I'm going to phone bank there.
I wouldn't waste my time arguing with D.C.
voters who aren't going to vote for Biden.
I just wouldn't think it's a waste of time.
Right.
OK, got me.
Yeah.
So thank you so much.
I do really appreciate your advice.
And you said I had been getting involved again
in, say, Pennsylvania, in Michigan.
So I'll just keep you in that.
Beautiful.
All right.
Have a great day.
Thanks, Eleanor.
Appreciate the phone call.
Yeah.
I mean, listen, guys, at this point, I don't
know that I when half the country doesn't
vote.
I don't know that I'd be arguing with anyone
even in the key states.
Don't argue with people.
Just identify the people who don't like Trump
and explain to them how important it is to
vote and how easy it can be to vote.
I think that's a much better investment of
time.